very popular car out here in Los Angeles  an electric car electric car yeah it's  in the shop now we're having a gas  Center put it up but I put in the Tesla  that's right because the gas has kind of  come down a little bit gotta take  advantage of that yeah it'll go back up  again who knows what's but do you like  it you like that electric car I do like  it yeah but you know I said the pharmacy  a couple days ago I saw that petroleum  jelly is not gone of one cent not in the  last 10 years how could I buy a lot of  petroleum jelly but I happen to notice  it has and I was thinking too bad our  cars couldn't run on petroleum jelly how  great would that be  it would be hard to get it in there  though but you get it in there you're  working in there do what you got to do  come on come on come on